welcome back
so in the last section of the course we
talked about this situation where the
response was quantitative
or regression
this in this section we're going to talk
about classification where the response
variable's got two or more values and
this is actually a very commonly
occurring problem
actually probably more commonly
occurring than regression uh in machine
learning especially there's a big
concentration on classification where
for example we're trying to predict
whether something whether email is good
email or spam or in a medical area
trying to predict whether a patient's
going to
survive or die with a given disease so
it's a very commonly occurring problem
and very important so we're going to
spend
some time today on this actually in the
next
uh
set of lectures on classification and
trevor and i are both here trevor is
going to give the
most of the talk and i'm going to pipe
in and
correct him when he makes mistakes and
make fun of his accent and things like
that that means we won't hear much from
you
we'll see
anyway let's go to the slides
the first thing we do is just show you
what what categorical variables look
like i'm sure you know so for example
eye color that takes on three values
brown blue and green
those are those are discrete values
there's no ordering they're just three
different values email we've talked
about already is spam and ham
i like that word ham i like ham i said
i wish i thought of it anyway ham is
good email so uh so
spam filters need to classify into spam
or ham
so what is a classifier
well
you've got a
feature vector x just like we had in
regression and now you have one of these
qualitative response variables like like
those above
and here's the mathy description of a of
a classifier
the response takes values into this in a
set c which is a
set of discrete values and the
classification task is to build a
function
takes x as input
and delivers one of the elements of the
set c and so that's how we this is how
we write it in
in math language
c of x
gives you values in the set c so for
example in the spam ham problem c of x
would either come back as spam or ham
now
although
classification problems are always
cashed in this form
we're often more interested in
estimating the probabilities that x
belongs to each category c
so for example it's more
valuable for a insurance company to have
an estimate of the probability that an
insurance claim is fraudulent then a
classification fraudulent or not
i mean you can imagine in the one
situation you might have
a probability of
a point
say nine that the
the um claim is fraudulent and in
another case it might be point
nine
eight
now in both cases those might both be
above the threshold of of raising a flag
that this is a fraudulent
insurance claim but if you're going to
look into the claim and you're going to
spend some hours investigating you
probably go for the 0.98 first
before the 0.9 so estimating the
probabilities is also key
okay so here's something yes
some data
two variables this is the credit card
default
data set that we're going to use in this
section
and the plot on the left here
is a scatter plot of
balance against income so those are two
of the variables
and as we can with classification
problems we can code the response
variable into the plot as a color
and so here we have the blue points and
the brown points
and the brown points are going to be
those that defaulted and the blue points
are those that did not now this is a
fictitious data set you typically don't
expect to see that many defaulters
but we'll talk about
balanced balance in in classification
tasks a little bit later as well
so it looks in this plot it looks like
balance is the important variable notice
that there's a
big separation between the
the blues
and the browns
the defaulters and those that didn't
okay whereas with income there doesn't
seem to be much separation at all
okay
in the right we actually show box plots
of these two variables
and so we see
for example for default
there's
oh a bigger pattern default is at the
bottom no yes no yes in both cases we've
got balance and we've got we've got
balance and we've got income
and here we also clearly see that
there's a big difference in the
distributions balance and income
sorry i begin pardon balance default or
not um whereas for income this hardly
seems to be any difference i've never
seen a box plot before what is that
oh
you tell me rob
okay
well let's see a box plot what's
indicated there trevor you can point the
the black line is the median
so there's a black line that's immediate
so that's the median the medium for the
the yes for the people
the median income for people who have
defaulted and then the top of the box
the book are where the quartiles that's
the 75th quartile
75th percentile
quartile and the 25th is the bottom of
the box
so really a good summary of of the
distribution
of income for those in category yes what
about these these things at the end rob
okay i think they're called hinges
and those are the ranges are they are
approximately the ranges of the data
yeah i think i think a hinge is defined
to be um
fraction of the
interquartile range and so it gives you
an idea of the spread of the data and if
data points fall outside the hinges they
they consider to be
outliers by the way it's a very useful
data display almost one of the first
things you should do when you get some
data to analyze is do some scatter plots
and do some blocks and create some box
plots who invented the box
john turkey john tukey one of the most
famous statisticians he's no longer with
us but he's left a big legacy behind
okay well
one question we can ask is
can we use linear regression to solve
classification problems
it seems like we may be able to so
suppose for the default classification
task that we code the response zero if
no default one if yes to default right
it's somewhat arbitrary but zero and one
seems sufficient
and then we could simply perform a
linear regression of y on x with x being
the the two predictors in this case
and classifies yes if y hat's bigger
than 0.5
50
right i mean 50.5 is halfway between 0
and 1 it seems like a reasonable idea
turns out that you actually can do this
for a binary outcome linear regression
does a pretty good job
and is equivalent to
linear discriminant analysis
and that's something we're going to
discuss later so for a two-class
classification problem like this doesn't
do a bad job at all
and there's even some theoretical
justification
in the population remember in in the
population we think of regression as
estimating the conditional mean of y
given x
well in our coding here of zero and one
the conditional mean of the zero one
variable given x is simply the
probability that y is one given x just
by simple probability theory so for that
reason you might think that regression
is is perfect for this task
what we're going to see have is that
linear regression might actually produce
probabilities that could be less than
zero or even bigger than one
and for this reason we're going to
introduce you to logistic regression
which is more appropriate
and here's a little picture that that
illustrates it here we've got our
balance variable
now we've plotted against balance we've
plotted the zeros at the bottom as
little dashes here the browns and the
little brown
spikes they're all
clumped together at the bottom and the
ones are plotted at the top here and we
see the separation the
the brown
zeros are towards the left of balance
and the and the ones are towards the
right
and the blue line is the linear
regression line
and lo and behold it goes below zero
so
that's not a very good estimate of a
probability
it also seems not to go high enough on
the right hand side where it seems clear
that there's a preponderance of of yeses
on the right hand side
on the in the right hand plot we've got
the fit of logistic regression and it
seems to do a pretty good job in this
case
it never gets outside of zero and one
and it seems to go up high where it's
meant to go up high
so
it seems things aren't looking terrific
for linear regression in terms of
estimating probabilities
so now what happens if we have a three
category variable so here's a resp
here's a variable that measures
a patient's condition at an emergency
room and it takes on three levels so
it's one if it's a stroke two if it's a
drug overdose and three if it's an
epileptic seizure
so
if we code those as say one two and
three which would be
a
arbitrary but natural choice
this coding might suggest an ordering
when in fact there's not necessarily an
order in here at all
and it might in fact imply that the
difference between stroke and drug
overdose which is one unit is the same
as the difference between drug overdose
and epileptic seizure
so when you have more than two
categories
assigning numbers to the categories just
arbitrarily
seems a little dangerous especially if
you're going to use it in linear
regression
and it turns out linear regression is
not appropriate here
and for for problems like this we
we're going to
prefer multi-class logistic regression
or discriminant analysis and both of
those we'll discuss